this video is brought to you by policy genius
if you have family members who depend on your
income you need life insurance that's where
policy genius comes in more on them in just a
bit after the victory over the british in the
revolutionary war the newly independent united
states of america found itself in a position to
build a new nation from the ground up but that
left some pressing questions how would this nation
be governed how much power should be allocated
to the federal government and how much should be
allocated to the individual states and how could
this new country ensure that its citizens would
prosper economically at the center of all three
of these questions was alexander hamilton who came
from the humblest backgrounds to rise to the very
upper echelons of the new american government
in doing so he became one of the most impactful
and controversial public servants the united
states has ever had everything about his
life seemed scripted for dramatic purposes
including his vile and death at the hands of
one of his political opponents and beyond
political historians and musical theater
fans few people know anything about
alexander hamilton beyond the fact
that his face adorns the 10 bill we hope
to change that today and let you decide if
hamilton was a prophet who successfully predicted
america's future rise or like his opponents
charged that he was satan incarnate drawing
his new country down the path of damnation
we know very little about alexander hamilton's
childhood because he rarely talked about it from
what we do know it isn't hard to see why he was
born on the 11th of january 1757 on the island
of nevis in the british west indies because
his parents weren't married he was declared
illegitimate a label that would follow him all of
his life and would normally have greatly impacted
his standing in society things got even worse
when alexander's father james hamilton abandoned
the family when he was a child and soon after
his mother rachel died of yellow fever rachel's
jealous husband johan lavian seized every penny
of her estate leaving alexander and his brother
james jr impoverished orphans the only thing
alexander had going for him was his exceptional
intelligence he was an avid reader and despite
receiving little formal education quickly figured
out the merchant's trade when employed as a
clerk for an import export firm in the islands
in 1772 the 15 year old hamilton wrote a letter to
his father describing a hurricane that had struck
the caribbean that was so well written that it was
published in the newspaper and community leaders
took up a collection to send this exceptional
boy to north america to be educated probably
hoping that hamilton would return to the
islands to practice a skilled trade such as
doctoral lawyer if that was their hope it was in
vain alexander hamilton left the west indies in
the fall of 1772 and never returned he never
saw his father or his brother again after a
year at prep school in new jersey hamilton
enrolled at king's college in new york city
today columbia university he wanted to become a
lawyer something that suited his talent for oral
and written argument well but like everyone
else in america he soon found himself caught
up in the convulsions that would reverberate
across the continent and eventually the world
hamilton had thrown himself wholeheartedly into
the patriot cause early on writing passionate
essays under pen names they were published in the
winter of 1774-1775 when torque devolved into war
in the spring of 1775 hamilton like many young
men volunteered for service in the various militia
companies that would soon be fashioned into the
continental army hamilton became captain of an
artillery company and saw action against the
british in the campaigns around new york city
which the british occupied after a successful
invasion in july 1776 hamilton's talent soon
attracted the attention of continental army
commander george washington who promoted him
to lieutenant colonel and appointed him as his
chief of staff in early 1777. as a member of
washington's military family he was far more
than a mere aide in many respects hamilton
was washington's right-hand man drafting orders
and letters on behalf of the commander-in-chief
negotiating with the continental congress
and senior army commanders on his behalf
and becoming involved in detailed matters of
diplomacy intelligence supply and logistics
and everything else needed to keep an army in
the field it was the start of a relationship
that would persist for the rest of their lives
washington who had no biological children probably
viewed the young hamilton as someone he could
mentor as a paternal figure while hamilton who
had latched on to surrogate fathers throughout
his life saw a man he could emulate and admire
the relationship between the two men would in
the coming decades shaped the course of american
history hamilton spent four years as washington's
chief of staff becoming well known throughout the
army as washington's man but hamilton was a young
man with the young man's thirst for glory and he
desperately wanted a field command he finally got
one in august 1781 just in time to participate in
the most important battle of the revolutionary war
washington's army in conjunction with america's
french allies had surrounded the british army of
lord cornwallis in yorktown virginia to complete
their encirclement of cornwallis's position
two small forts known as redoubts 9 and 10
needed to be seized colonel hamilton was named
commander of the american effort to recapture
redoubt number 10 while the french seized number
nine in a nighttime action on october the 14th
400 american soldiers led by hamilton stormed the
redoubt a bare net point capturing the position
after heavy hand-to-hand fighting with the
french also succeeding in capturing their target
cornwallis fate was sealed five days later eight
thousand soldiers marched out of yorktown having
surrendered to the americans and the french even
though new york would be occupied by the british
until 1783 for all intents and purposes the war
was over and america had won her independence
alexander hamilton returned to new york city
and finished his legal training in july 1782.
he plunged into legal work with the same energy he
put into everything else quickly becoming one of
new york's most prominent attorneys he also raised
a large family with his wife eliza eventually the
couple would have eight children between 1782 and
1802 but hamilton had turned his eye toward a new
passion by then politics in the 1780s the new
nation won by blood shed by men like hamilton
was in crisis the united states was governed by
a document known as the articles of confederation
under the articles the federal government was
incredibly weak only being able to act with the
consent of all 13 states and since the states
never seemed to agree on anything nothing was
getting done there was no way to mitigate disputes
between states who at times acted like independent
countries onto themselves and if things continued
the way they were then it was just a matter of
time before the country tore itself apart hamilton
served in the congress of the confederation and
knew exactly how poor it was he joined a growing
chorus of politicians who called for the articles
to be replaced in may 1787 hamilton was chosen
as one of three representatives from new york
to the constitutional convention in philadelphia
hamilton's influence at the convention was limited
by the two other new york delegates who belonged
to a faction controlled by new york governor
george clinton that was opposed to any reform that
would take power away from his state despite this
the other delegates headed by convention president
george washington hammered out a brand new united
states constitution over the course of four
months that created a new federal government
made up of an elected president and a congress
who would make laws that covered all the states
but the new constitution would only go into
effect if nine of the 13 states ratified it
in state conventions something that wasn't
guaranteed hamilton wanted to help convince
the american people that the new constitution
was not only necessary but it benefited them
then they would put pressure on their legislators
to ratify it hamilton enlisted the help of two
other passionate supporters of the constitution
fellow new yorker john jay and virginian james
madison and they would write a series of articles
explaining it to the public written under the
pseudonym publius the series of 85 articles was
published in major newspapers between october 1787
and april 1788. the federalist papers as they are
known today explained in painstaking detail all
of the flaws of the articles of confederation as
well as an in-depth explanation of each article
of the new constitution including how it benefited
the average american citizen the federalist papers
were an immediate sensation being widely
read across the country and eventually
published in a two-volume book in 1788 the barrage
of well-written and explained arguments in favor
of the constitution overwhelmed any opposition
the people began to clamor for their state
legislatures to adopt the new document on june
21 1788 new hampshire became the ninth state
to ratify the constitution officially putting it
into effect one month later hamilton's home state
of new york finally ratified it rather than risk
being left out of the union of the other states
though the identity of publius was officially
a secret most everyone knew that alexander
hamilton was one of the principal authors of
the federalist papers and he would be closely
associated with the strong central government laid
out in the constitution for the rest of his life
now just before we continue with today's video
a quick word from today's wonderful sponsor
policy genius look no one likes to think about
life insurance because it means that you're
going to be thinking about death but the reality
is that it's an important layer of protection
for many families especially single-income
households fortunately this policy genius and
their award-winning policy options ranked number
one by forbes whether you've been putting off your
purchase or just never really thought about it
policy genius is the team that you want to check
in with this is a third-party marketplace that
works for you not for the insurance company so you
can trust that their licensed experts are going
to give you solid unbiased advice life insurance
premiums might seem like a financial drain but
you could save 1 300 or more per year by using
policy genius to compare life insurance policies
if you're interested head to policygenius.com to
get started and in just a few minutes you can
work out how much coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best price when
you're ready to apply the policy genius team or
handle the paperwork and the scheduling for free
you could save 50 or more in life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius and getting
covered now locks in your rate over the course of
a 10 or 20-year policy those savings really do
add up and best of all eligible applicants can
get covered in as little as a week so head to
policygenius.com to get started you'll be glad
you did because when it comes to insurance it's
nice to get it right and now back to today's video
on april 30 1789 george washington took the oath
of office as the first president of the united
states having been universally elected by the
electoral college the constitution did not specify
how the executive branch of government of which
the revolutionary war hero was now the head was
to conduct its business leaving washington
to construct the apparatus of governments
around him he decided to ask congress to
create three new government departments
state war and treasury the secretaries of
these departments appointed by the president
and confirmed by the senate would together with
the attorney general formed the cabinet a group
of men who would oversee the everyday business
of executive government and advise the president
on policy matters almost 250 years later this
is still how the executive branch functions
though today's cabinet is made up of 25 members
instead of four washington's trusted wartime aide
decarb alexander hamilton was selected by the
president to serve as the first secretary of the
treasury the department that was to oversee the
fledgling country's fragile economy confirmed by
the senate in september hamilton immediately got
to work with his usual gusto the first problem
was the biggest the government had no money to pay
for its business the entire country suffered from
a lack of ready cash and the obvious solution was
to borrow money but with no established credit
rating none of the large european banks were
willing to give the united states government
a loan to resolve this hamilton proposed to create
a public debt using debts incurred by the various
states during the revolutionary war which the
federal government would assume if he could
show the u.s could pay back its internal debt
then foreign banks would feel confident that it
could pay back any international debts incurred in
addition the bonds could be traded by speculators
known as stock jabbers as currency which would
stimulate the american economy hamilton ran
into unexpectedly fierce opposition from a group
of political figures headed by the newly appointed
secretary of state thomas jefferson jefferson
had been involved with the american experiment
from the beginning he was the principal author
of the declaration of independence but jefferson
was skeptical of the constitution and
mistrusted a strong federal government
taking on a public debt increased the power of
the federal government and opened the door to
possible corruption which jefferson associated
with tyrannical rule president washington wanted
both men in his cabinet as he believed both would
offer valuable service to the new government he
encouraged them to find a compromise and there was
something jefferson's faction wanted the federal
capital it was currently located in new york city
but southern politicians like jefferson wanted
it moved further south closer to their states a
deal was struck the capital would be moved first
to philadelphia and then eventually to a planned
federal site on the potomac river that formed the
border between maryland and virginia in exchange
the revolutionary war dead would be assumed by the
federal government hamilton was a new yorker at
heart and he knew losing the capital would hurt
his home city but he also knew it was what was
best for the country as a whole so he agreed
and so it was that washington dc was born and
the foundation of the american economy was laid
the deal between hamilton and jefferson over the
capital was the last time the two founding fathers
were able to work together on anything the two men
were fairly similar to each other and in another
life they could have probably been close friends
but both men were stubbornly committed to their
principles believing the future of the nation
was at stake and they both had wildly different
ideas about what direction the united states
should take jefferson a plantation owner who
owned hundreds of slaves believed that a largely
agrarian nation populated by small-holding farmers
was the most democratic form for an economy
to take in foreign policy he favored france
believing the upheavals of the french revolution
were a continuation of the american struggle
to overthrow monarchy most importantly he
favored a weak federal government that was
subordinate to the whims of state government
particularly large ones like virginia he and
his supporters like hamilton's collaborator
on the federalist papers james madison
formed a faction they called democratic
republicans today historians refer to them
as the jeffersonian republicans to differentiate
them from the modern democratic and republican
parties alexander hamilton by contrast believed
the future of america lay not in farming but in
commerce through manufacturing and trade because
90 percent of american trade at the time came
through great britain hamilton favored them
not because he wanted to restore british rule
in america but because he believed it benefited
his nation economically and he believed that the
best way to govern the country was through a
strong federal government with broad authority
he and his faction were called federalists george
washington was officially neutral not belonging
to either of the two factions in fact he cautioned
against forming political parties at all believing
they would lead to the downfall of the republic
but he was unable to keep members of the cabinet
from gearing up for an all-out assault on each
other their weapon of choice was the country's
newspapers newspapers of the period contained very
little objective reporting instead they were a
vehicle for partisan writers to exhort their cause
and to attack their opponents through a series of
long opinion pieces most of these were written
under pen names but everybody knew who the authors
were on the federalist side this was frequently
alexander hamilton where jefferson preferred to
avoid direct confrontation and used proxies
all the while hamilton continued to work
moulding the american economy into his vision
he founded a national bank established a u.s
mint in philadelphia to produce currency formed
the u.s coast guard to prevent smuggling a big
problem when most of the government's money
came from customs duties and worked to expand
domestic manufacturing and to end the country's
over alliance and foreign imports washington
generally sided with hamilton in disputes between
his treasury and state secretary something that
incensed jefferson to the point that he resigned
as post at the end of 1793. by now jefferson
was convinced that not only was hamilton taking
the country down the wrong path but that he was
actively corrupt probably enriching himself either
through stock jobbing or through secret deals with
the british the attacks in hamilton's policies
turned increasingly personal portraying him as an
evil shadow lurking behind the chair of
the noble washington some of the more
vicious attacks criticized his foreign origins
and even his illegitimacy all of this weighed
heavily on hamilton he felt underappreciated he
was also heavily in debt and able to support his
family on his government salary certainly there
was no hidden fortune derived from corruption
finally on january 31 1795 hamilton resigned
as treasury secretary returning to private life
in 1796 george washington decided not to
run for a third term as president wanting to
avoid the perception that it was a post that
one person should hold for life washington's
magnaminity set up the first competitive election
in the country's history the logical choice for
hamilton and the federalists was to support
the vice president john adams believing him
to be the only person who could defeat thomas
jefferson something that was proved out when
adams was elected president but john adams was
no george washington adams has spent decades in
public service having collaborated with jefferson
on the declaration of independence and serving as
foreign ambassador to the courts of europe but
in all that time adams had never developed the
thick skin needed to work in politics he took even
the smallest slide personally and held grudges for
a long time he spent months at a time outside of
the capital in his home of massachusetts dictating
his orders via letters and most importantly
for hamilton adams wanted nothing to do with
him scorning his advice hamilton chafed at the
loss of influence and looked for a way to get
back into the action revolutionary france provided
him with that opportunity the united states had
concluded a trade deal with great britain a few
years earlier the controversial j treaty the
french who were at war with britain viewed this as
a betrayal and a series of diplomatic skirmishes
threatened to descend into war president adams
felt he had no choice but to raise an army to
defend the country in the face of a possible
french invasion a natural choice to command
this army was george washington but washington
would only accept the command if his second in
command was alexander hamilton so hamilton was
appointed a major general in 1798 with washington
ailing at his home in mount vernon hamilton
effectively ran the army taking charge of training
organization and supplies adams didn't want war
with france or anyone else pinning his hopes on a
diplomatic solution this brought him into conflict
with hamilton who still clung to boyish notions
of military glory everything started to go wrong
for hamilton at once his great friend and patron
george washington died in 1799. adams stripped
funding for the army privately worrying that
hamilton wanted to march on the capitol and set
himself up as a dictator america's first political
sex scandal came to light as newspaper reports
revealed the spicy details of an affair hamilton
had in 1792 with a woman named maria reynolds who
it appeared was extorting him for money to keep
the affair a secret hamilton in a bizarre display
decided to admit to the affair in a published
pamphlet that was widely circulated hamilton
wanted to defend himself from corruption charges
but the pamphlet just made things worse things
came to a head in 1800 when hamilton furious at
john adams for dismantling his army after a peace
deal with napoleon was reached turned his pen on
the president attacking his fitness for office
and endorsing a south carolina federalist charles
pickney instead many people privately agreed with
hamilton about adams character but the attack
on adam split the federalist vote ensuring the
election of hamilton's greatest rival jefferson
to the highest office adams never forgave
hamilton and spent the rest of his life attacking
hamilton's character in print as for hamilton
the political blunders seemed to have destroyed
his own career which probably prevented him from
having any chance of running for president himself
in 1804 vice president aaron burr was a man with
no friends in the election of 1800 he had been
the jeffersonian candidate for vice president by
the way the constitution was originally written
whoever got the most electoral votes became
president and the runner-up became vice president
the problem with this came when the top two
candidates in this case jefferson and burr tied
in the electoral vote throwing the election to
the house of representatives burr was a political
opportunist and used the tie votes to try and gain
the office for himself at the expense of jefferson
courting disgruntled federalists to try and vote
for him instead this didn't work and the newly
elected vice president found himself shut out of
jefferson's government everyone knew that when
jefferson came up for re-election in 1804 burr was
going to be dropped from the ticket burr decided
that his next move was to run for governor of his
home state of new york hoping to build a following
there for a possible return to washington but what
was left of alexander hamilton's power base was in
new york and if there was one man hamilton didn't
want him power it was aaron burr hamilton believed
that burr only cared about himself and that he
had no principles except whatever would ensure
his own advancement he disliked burst so much that
he campaigned in the house for jefferson and the
1800 thai election a strange irony that was not
lost to hamilton in 1804 hamilton campaigned to
hard for burr's opponent morgan lewis playing a
key role in his victory in that race burr hadn't
forgotten hamilton's politicking in 1800 and felt
that this was the second time the former secretary
of the treasury had derailed his political
ambitions he challenged hamilton to a pistol duel
duels or affairs of honor were holdovers from
the days of chivalry a form of ritualized murder
in which the two combatants stood 20 paces apart
and shot at each other people dying in duels was
relatively rare it was more about demonstrating
their bravery and being willing to face down death
in the name of honor in that way it was more a
show of political grandstanding than anything else
burr wanted to try and use a showdown with
hamilton to resurrect his failing political
career and hamilton never wanted to back down
from a challenge happily obliged him hamilton
let it be known in the days preceding the duel
that he had no intention of trying to kill
burr he intended to throw away his shot by firing
his gun in the air a demonstration that he held
no ill-will towards his opponent many such duels
ended this way with both combatants walking away
unscathed their personal honor intact dueling
was illegal in new york so the two men met across
the river in new jersey on the morning of july the
11th 1804. in an ironic twist of fate it was the
same spot where two years earlier hamilton's
eldest son philip had been killed in a duel
himself hamilton probably fired first and his shot
missed probably on purpose burst shot did not miss
the bullet struck hamilton in the abdomen
doing major damage to his internal organs and
lodging in his spine hamilton knew immediately
that he'd been mortally wounded he was taken back
to his home in new york where he lasted until
the next day saying goodbye to his distraught
wife and children as well as his friends he was
only 49 when the bullet finally claimed his life
the death of alexander hamilton proved to be the
death now for the federalist party that he led
jeppesen's party now held unchallenged ascendancy
as jeffersonian republicans held the presidency
from 1800 to 1824 but hamilton's financial system
which jefferson hated so much survived because
as jefferson's treasury secretary albert
gallatin pointed out the system was so perfectly
constructed any attempt to dismantle it would harm
the country in fact when president james madison
allowed the first bank of the united states to
expire during his administration it precipitated
a financial crisis that forced him to sheepishly
found the second bank of the united states
to restore american finance hamilton's death
also killed the political career of aaron burr
though he escaped murder charges filed against
him he never held another office after his term
as vice president ended in 1805. he spent the rest
of his life moving from place to place as a pariah
never showing remorse for killing hamilton
hamilton meanwhile was widely mourned especially
in new york city his funeral on july the 14th
was the largest in the city's long history
every business in new york was closed that day and
so many people marched in the funeral procession
that it took hours to complete not everyone was
sorry to see hamilton die though his two longtime
political antagonists john adams and thomas
jefferson lived two decades after hamilton's
death and their long-standing grievances against
the man made their way into their writings that
were published for posterity hamilton wasn't
around to defend himself or write his memoirs
explaining what he did and why which surely
would have been a masterpiece of literature
it has only been recently that hamilton's
reputation has undergone a re-evaluation
most particularly through a widely successful
broadway musical based on hamilton's life
it's remarkable how accurate alexander hamilton's
predictions about the american economy were
hamilton believed that commerce was the key to the
new country's future he predicted the industrial
revolution the rise of manufacturing to replace
farming the primacy of cities over rural areas
the power of stock trading and banking and the
national debt in short it's everything that makes
modern capitalism function equally important
every president after george washington has
built on the power of the executive branch first
proposed by alexander hamilton the united states
has a robust federal government that keeps the
many states bound together precisely because
men like hamilton believed that this was the
only way to keep the country from inevitably
splitting itself apart whether you think the
legacy he left makes him a hero or a villain
you have to admit that few of the founding fathers
achieved more than he did few other americans have
ever started as lowly as he did and risen as
high and the tragedy of his life is that we'll
never know what else he might have been able to
achieve had he not been cut down in his prime
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching